space it's infinitely big and there are
an infinite number of things in it but
there are not an infinite number of
different kinds of things so this is my
attempt to try and collect all of the
different kinds of things in space in
one video looking up from our earth into
the sky we see our solar system at the
centres our Sun the yellow dwarf style
that's lived for about 4.6 billion years
and will live for 5 billion more before
burning out around the Sun orbit the
terrestrial planets which we made mostly
of silicate rocks or metals and the
gaseous planets which is split into the
gas giants which were mostly made of
hydrogen and helium and the ice giants
which are made of heavier elements like
oxygen carbon nitrogen and sulfur in
between Mars and Jupiter we've got an
asteroid belt which is the relic of the
stuff of the early solar system which we
think never formed a planet due to the
strong gravitational effect of Jupiter
there are other asteroids in the solar
system some of which become meteoroids
when they hit the Earth's atmosphere and
we get comets which have highly
elliptical orbits around the Sun and
were caused by the outward motion of
Neptune 4.5 billion years ago we also
have dwarf planets which haven't managed
to clear their orbits of other objects
like Ceres in the asteroid belt and
Pluto and others in the Kuiper belt
which is a region beyond Neptune similar
to the asteroid belt but far wider
containing many small bodies made of
rock and metal and of course we have
moons like our Moon and the moons around
other planets beyond the Kuiper belt we
have the Oort cloud a theoretical cloud
of icy objects surrounding the Sun in
all directions and finally we have the
heliosphere a large bubble around the
solar system created by particles coming
from the Sun called the solar wind
hitting particles from the rest of the
galaxy the interstellar medium and of
course we mustn't forget cosmic dust
microscopic collections of matter
scattered throughout the universe
looking beyond our solar system we get
to our galaxy the Milky Way made of
about 400 billion other stars spinning
in a giant spiral the solar system takes
back 250 million years to orbit the
Milky Way and it's done this about 20
times in the lifetime of us
in the center of the Milky Way is a
supermassive black hole with a mass 4.6
million times that of the Sun we think
there's probably a supermassive black
hole at the center of every galaxy and
they can have masses of up to a billion
times that of our Sun when we look up
into the night sky most of what we see
are stars and there are many different
kinds of stars in the galaxy
95% of stars of main-sequence stars
which break down into red dwarf orange
dwarf and yellow dwarf stars red dwarf
stars are the smallest much smaller than
the radius of the Sun but the
longest-lived estimated to live for
thousands of billions of years due to
their slow burn orange dwarf stars are a
bit smaller than the Sun and will live
for tens of billions of years and yellow
dwarves like our Sun live for about 4 to
17 billion years before expanding into
red giant stars smaller than red dwarfs
are brown dwarfs which aren't really
stars because they were never massive
enough to create fusion in their cores
they're about the same size as Jupiter
but have at least 13 times the mass the
brightness of many stars varies over
time and these are known as variable
stars there are a few different kinds
intrinsic variable stars the luminosity
actually changes due to a change in size
whereas with extrinsic variables the
brightness changes because of an
orbiting companion moving in front of it
like a binary star system or extrasolar
planets and some giant or supergiant
stars have irregular changes in
luminosity Cepheid variable stars are
very valuable to us because they've got
large variations in both size and
temperature with a very stable frequency
because of this strong relationship
between you manasa T and the frequency
they pulsate they're used to determine
accurate distances in the universe
they're known as standard candles much
bigger than the main sequence stars are
the blue giants with a radius of 1.4 to
250 times the radius of the Sun and much
shorter lives existing for three to four
thousand million years at the end of
their lives they can cool into red giant
super giants or hyper giant stars red
giant stars of a radius of 20 to a
hundred times the radius of the Sun and
burn for a few hundred million to two
billion years before exploding to make a
planetary nebula with their cause
shrinking into a white dwarf star
the white dwarf star is also the final
destination for orange and red dwarf
stars white dwarf stars make up 4% the
stars in the galaxy in a tiny and dense
roughly the mass of the Sun squeezed
into the size of the earth and their
dead no fusion is going on in their
cores and they only glow due to their
residual heat energy they will live for
trillions and trillions of years growing
dimmer and dimmer until they end up as
black dwarfs which don't yet exist
because the universe hasn't been alive
for long enough white dwarfs will be the
final state for more than 97% of the
stars in the universe for the truly
massive stars a different cosmic journey
awaits the red super and hyper Giants
have much shorter lives with only 3
million to 100 million years these
colossal stars with radius is a hundred
to two thousand times that of the Sun in
their lives in a shoe mongers explosion
known as a supernova where they throw
off their outer layers into a nebula
known as a supernova remnant while the
core collapses into either a neutron
star or a black hole stars larger than
40 times the mass of the Sun are likely
to collapse into a black hole an object
so dense and massive that not even light
can escape its gravity this makes them
completely dark and at their centers a
gravitational singularity rips a hole in
the fabric of space-time they are the
most extreme and fascinating objects in
our universe four stars that are not
massive enough to form a black hole they
collapse into a neutron star where the
combined gravity of the insane mass of
the star overcomes the ability of
electrons to keep atoms separate the
atoms collapse the electrons and protons
combine into more neutrons and it forms
an incredibly dense ball of neutrons
like a giant atomic nucleus they have a
mass of about 1.4 times the mass of the
Sun but squeezed into a radius of only 5
to 15 kilometers this is so incredibly
dense a sugar cube sized piece of
neutron star would weigh as much as
Mount Everest neutron stars are normally
left spinning very quickly and they've
got incredibly strong magnetic fields
millions of times stronger than anything
we've ever created on earth
this magnetic fields fuse our
electromagnetic radiation at the poles
and as they spin around it sweeps a beam
across the universe making a precise
pulse when it passes these are called
pulsars and some of them revolve
incredibly quickly several hundred times
a second which is just mad the neutron
stars with the strongest magnetic fields
are known as magnet ours and they could
be the explanation for mysterious
signals we see in the sky like soft
gamma repeaters and anomalous x-ray
pulsars an x-ray pulsar is a binary
system where a normal star in a neutron
star are orbiting around each other the
neutron star sucks matter from the main
star creating high energy beams of
x-rays at the poles I've covered the
death of stars but what about their
births stars formed from the gas and
dust of the stars that exploded in the
distant past clouds we call nebulae
protoplanetary nebula is the final
stages of the formation of a solar
system the star and planets forming out
of the gas and dust there are many other
kinds of nebulae too an h2 region is a
cloud of ionized hydrogen gas where star
formation is taking place an emission
nebula is where a nearby hot star
ionizes its gas and then it emits light
at different frequencies however if the
light from the star is not energetic
enough to ionize the gas instead it will
scatter off it making a reflection
nebula in some nebulae are so dense they
blocked light coming through these are
called dark nebulae in the final feature
of a galaxy a star clusters which come
in two categories globular clusters are
tight groups of hundreds to millions of
stars which are gravitationally bound
while open clusters are a few hundred
stars that are more loosely spread out
and are not gravitationally bound until
about a hundred years ago we thought
that the Milky Way contain all of the
stars in the universe until Edwin Hubble
showed that the Milky Way was just one
galaxy of many and now we know that
there are one to two trillion galaxies
in the observable universe
the Milky Way galaxy is a spiral galaxy
but other galaxies broadly break down
into elliptical spiral and barred spiral
galaxies shell galaxies are elliptical
galaxies which are made from concentric
shells of stars then ticular galaxies
fall somewhere in between elliptical and
spiral galaxies occasionally galaxies
collide and interact because of this
some galaxies don't fit these broad
categories for example ringed galaxies
have an empty core and a ring-like
collection of stars around it which may
have been caused by a smaller galaxy
moving through the middle of the larger
one and irregular galaxies are those
that have a strange shape due to some
interaction in the past there are super
luminous galaxies four times bigger than
the Milky Way but most galaxies in the
universe are a lot smaller than ours and
they're called dwarf galaxies containing
a few billion stars about a hundredth
the size of the Milky Way and often they
orbit the larger galaxies some galaxies
a very active galactic cores where
material falls into the central
supermassive black hole creating Jets of
particles traveling close to the speed
of light these are called blazars if the
Jets are pointing directly at us but
radio galaxies if the Jets is pointing
away as all we see are the radio waves
being emitted by the Jets quasars are
the most distant and most energetic of
the active galaxies their central cause
emitting up to a hundred times the
luminosity of the entire Milky Way now
we get to the mysterious things in the
universe things we see but don't
understand gamma-ray bursts are insanely
energetic bursts of electromagnetic
radiation from distant galaxies and the
brightest events that occur in the
universe we think that they come from
massive stars exploding in a supernova
or from mergers of neutron stars fast
radio bursts of mysterious short pulses
of radio waves caused by some
high-energy process generating as much
energy in a millisecond as the Sun does
in 80 years some of these fast radio
bursts are repeating coming from the
same source over and over again and we
have no idea what is causing them dark
matter is a mysterious form of matter
that gives galaxies extra mass without
it they would fly apart even though it
makes up
proximately 85% of the matter in the
universe we don't know what this dark
matter is because it doesn't interact
with our ordinary matter our best guess
is that it's some form of undiscovered
subatomic particle flying around in
space but we've got no evidence for this
yet the solar system and galaxies are
held together with gravity because
gravity pulls things together but when
we look at galaxies in the distant
universe we see that they're
accelerating away from us this is really
weird because it means that there's a
mysterious force throughout the galaxy
that's pushing everything apart in an
accelerating rate like a kind of
anti-gravity we call it dark energy and
it makes up 68% of the energy in the
universe even though we've given it a
name we've got no idea what it is as we
go to the largest scales in the universe
we see galaxies clusters then super
clusters and the dark voids between them
then we get to the Cosmic Microwave
Background the signal from when the
universe first became transparent
380,000 years after the Big Bang behind
this we can't see anything with lights
but we will be able to peer behind it
with gravitational wave astronomy right
back to the Big Bang which is as far as
we'll ever be able to see in the
universe this makes it the edge of the
observable universe at 46 billion
light-years away we know that there's
still stuff further away from us than
that but we'll never see it because it's
traveling away from us faster than the
speed of light and I said at the
beginning the universe is infinite but
we don't actually know whether the
universe is infinite or finite does
another mystery to be solved so that's
the universe all in one go at least most
of it they did have to drop a few things
for the sake of time let me know in the
comments if you think I've missed
anything important and one thing that is
finite is this poster which can get your
hands on links in the description below
and I've heard from some of my
subscribers that they're not seeing my
latest videos pop up on their feet this
is a thing that happens sometimes on
YouTube and the solution is to press the
notification Bell next to the subscribe
button so if this is happening to you
that's what to do also big thanks to my
patreon supporters your support means I
can justify spending the time that it
takes
make this high-quality science content
and if you'd like to join the gang check
out my patreon page here alright thanks
for watching and I'll see you on the
next video
[Music]